The Simpsons isn't subject to the
regular rules of television and because
of that a lot of plots and fates are
left dangling never to be resolved so
we're looking at some big questions that
the Simpsons posed over the years and
which it never fully answered the
Simpsons has been on so long that its
opening sequence is almost as famous as
to show itself with more than six
hundred episodes under its belt most
Simpsons fans could recall it from
memory
we've got Bart writing a sentence on a
classroom blackboard wall a few dozen
times as punishment police are getting
kicked out of band practice for playing
jazz
Maggie getting picked up with Marge's
groceries and being swiped across a
cashiers barcode scanner and Homer
cutting out of work when he hears the
whistle blow carelessly allowing a
nuclear rod to bounce around after him
every one of these events warrants some
inspection Bart abandons the chalkboard
when he hears a school bell ring but why
does a bell ring when this is obviously
his after-school punishment and why is
Lisa's band class often depicted as part
of her regular school day being held
after class these events suggest that
it's about three or four o'clock which
seems early for homers nine to five gig
to end as for Maggie getting scanned a
price pops up for the grocery cashier
meaning Maggie is seemingly wearing a
bar code according to the Telegraph
Simpsons creator Matt Groening stated
that the price that appears on the
register is 847 dollars and 63 cents it
was the cost of raising a child in 1989
when the show first appear of a fox a
running gag in The Simpsons was an only
hilarious wordplay but its
characterization of Bart Simpson as a
rude cynical troublemaker Bart would
call Moe's Tavern and asked to speak
with someone and he'd always give a
made-up name that was either an insult
or a pun Moe would then call out to the
assorted barflies Seymour butts Bart
would then descend into a pit of giggles
and realizing he'd been pranked yet
again Moe would threaten acts of
violence against the caller should he
ever discover their identity but Moe
should have figured out over a dozen
times that his frequent prank caller is
the eldest Simpson child Homer is one of
most best customers and Moe is a family
friend but it's good that we the
audience get to enjoy his ongoing
confusion C Montgomery burns is the town
villain who owns the Springfield nuclear
power plant
he once blocked the Sun a stolen puppies
Andy's incredibly old he's fond of using
timely insults like dunder pate answers
the phone by saying illegally and tries
to sack his company softball team with
dead professional baseball players
Burns's age is clearly just a vehicle
for jokes and hilariously archaic worked
but it doesn't make his age clear his
birth year has been given both his 1881
and 1890 making him at least 100 in the
Simpsons universe but in the season four
episode last exit to Springfield there's
a flashback to burns as a boy in 1909
visiting in an atom smashing mill as a
school-aged boy placing his birth around
1900 also in the season 2 episode
Simpson and Delilah burns his age is
said to be 81 although in a few other
episodes that age changes to 104 and
when Springfield's oldest man dies at
age 108 Burns takes his place he could
even be older but it's obvious that the
writers won't make it clear or let this
joke die in the sixth season episode
fear of flying homer is rewarded for
helping an airline hide its cover-up by
mistaking him for a pilot but the
resulting trip is canceled because Marge
suffers a panic attack while awaiting
takeoff they get off the plane and Marge
sees the psychiatrist to find the cause
of her fear of flying a repressed memory
reveals that Marge hates blind because
when she was very young she found out
her father was secretly a flight
attendant and not a pilot like she had
thought at the end of the episode
Marge's cured of her fear and gets on a
plane with the family only for to run
off the runway and crashed into a lake
marge is deep discomfort with flying
remains both intact and justified
something which doesn't mesh with events
in earlier seasons the Simpsons family
goes on to take multiple vacations and
trips via airplane March included she
never seems to be anything but totally
comfortable and relaxed before and
during these air voyages according to
The Simpsons wiki it's theorized that
the episodes are out of order
which could explain Marches inconsistent
comfort with flying a permanent fixture
at Moe's Tavern is Barney Gumble he
seemingly always inebriated or in the
process of becoming inebriated
Barney's obvious alcoholism is a dark
but frequent source of comedy it once
won the Springfield Film Festival with
his beautiful and haunting movie about
his battle with a bottle and viewers
learned that he had a promising future
until Homer gave him his first beer the
night before the SATs setting Barney on
a drunken
black Ramos's to dyspeptic as the
boolean is too effervescent all right
Harvard here I come in the season 11
episode days of wine and doses
Barney swears off beer joins Alcoholics
Anonymous and adjusts to a life in
recovery but his addictive tendencies
still run deep and he still hangs out at
the bar because mobizen espresso machine
we're after Barney eliminates his
dependency on alcohol by getting hooked
on caffeine a well-groomed barney is
shown drinking latte after latte
until one day barney is once more
permanently a slob knocking back
brewskis so what exactly led Barney to
fall off the wagon and why unfortunately
we haven't gotten an answer yet
throughout the series Homer meets lots
of new people and invents makes or
schemes his way into just about
everything in the season 2 episode oh
brother where art thou homers estranged
half-brother herb is a successful car
company owner who lets Homer design a
car that's such a flop it destroys the
company and leaves and destitute after
being homeless for a while her
pre-tournament 3 brother can you spare
two dimes and stays with the Simpson
family for a while until he gets back on
his feet with Maggie's help herb
develops a baby translator and it's an
instant success that makes him wildly
rich once more the show is appreciation
he buys Homer the expensive luxury
recliner he's had his eye on this
episode hinges upon two very important
objects a device that unlocks the
language of infants and a huge piece of
furniture but the two objects are never
addressed again on The Simpsons a baby
translator would change the world but is
never mentioned again and hundreds of
scenes have transpired in the Simpsons
TV room with Homer firmly planted on the
couch and not his fancy chair in the
season 4 episode Marge vs. the monorail
frivolously spending town money on a
transit system seemed like such a
futuristic and progressive idea it even
had a catchy song introduced by monorail
proprietor Lyle an Li convincing them to
give land lay the cash windfall
collected from mr. burns for crimes
against the environment of course the
monorail was a civic financial and
political disaster but no ramifications
are fallout ever seemed to transpire not
only is Main Street still all cracked
and broken as Marge pointed out in the
monorail song but the tower was left in
far worse shape when a makeshift anchor
to stop the runaway monorail ripped
through several streets in
did Springfield fix all those roads and
if so how did the cash-strapped town pay
for it or the monorail towers tracks and
trains still hanging around Springfield
there's also the whereabouts of Lyle LAN
Li to wonder about little lady I'd love
to but I have to catch a plane but the
ride only takes a minute yeah well my
plane leaves in less than one minute
he built the monorail on the cheap and
escaped with the rest of the cash only
for his getaway plane to perform an
emergency landing in another town he
victimized where an angry mob confronted
him it's possible those town folk threw
him in jail on charges of criminal
negligence but it still doesn't account
for the instantaneous recovery of
Springfield the season 12 episode the
computer war menace shoes is undoubtedly
one of the strangest of the simpsons
catalog Homer starts a website then
spreads rumors and conspiracy theories
that he makes up until he accidentally
gets one right when he tells the public
that flu shots are performed just before
Christmas to incite the mass urge to
shop he's sent to his strange spooky and
surreal island prison among the
occupants are a man who invented a
bottomless peanut bag homers German
speaking doppelganger and a bunch of
menacing bubbles
Homer manages to escape and return home
only to be greeted by Santa's Little
Helper who sprays gas on him in the rest
of the family who later wake up in a
state of drugged-out bliss on the island
then the scene fades to black and the
credits roll the penal island is a
lengthy tribute to the bizarre 1960s
British TV series the prisoner but this
episode isn't established like many
Simpsons Treehouse of Horror segments
for all viewers know the real Simpsons
are still on that island The Simpsons
has been on the air for 30 years and as
time marches on people pass away several
longtime voice actors on the series have
died including marcia wallace who boys
Springfield Elementary teacher Edna
Krabappel and Russi Taylor who voiced
twins Sherri and Terry and nerd Martin
Prince Simpsons writers have approached
how to handle character departures of
deceased cast members in different ways
when Wallace died mrs. Krabappel died -
and her death was noticed in morn in
particular by her husband Ned Flanders
when Taylor passed on her child
characters survived voiced by new cast
member Gregg Delilah Griffon of course
the first big death on The Simpsons came
when Phil Hartman passed away
1998 producers opted to instantly retire
his recurring characters washed-up
b-movie actor Troy McClure and Simpson
family attorney Lionel Hutz writers
simply didn't include the characters
anymore and neither was ever mentioned
again while we know the tragic details
apartments passing the fates of these
characters have never been discussed the
season 7 episode much of who about
nothing takes on the issues of
immigration or rather how politicians
blame government shortfalls on illegal
immigrants in Springfield this
transpires when a bear patrol leads to a
tiny tax increase which upsets a citizen
so much that mayor Quimby blames the new
tax on immigrants voters then decide on
proposition 24 which would immediately
deport every illegal immigrant living in
Springfield in fear of the measure
passing kwik-e-mart owner and operator
of who frantically studies for the
citizenship test
bartender Moe is also shown taking the
test as his stereotypical Italian chef
Luigi appu passes and Moe and Luigi
presumably do too as both remain in town
when prop 24 passes in a landslide
however the episode ends with a
resentful groundskeeper Willie on a boat
dressed in the style of a 19th century
European arriving at Ellis Island
sailing away from Springfield
nevertheless Willie is present in later
episodes it's unclear how he was able to
return to town and his job so quickly
and easily it's not clear if he took a
citizenship test or arranged for legal
immigration or if he somehow snuck back
into Springfield from Scotland The
Simpsons has always been a satirical
show holding an animated mirror up to
society to point out its ills and make
fun of them
one target the show never tires of our
big corporations that do bad things
Homer works for the Springfield nuclear
power plants were skirting environmental
law in the name of profits for owner mr.
burns is the norm as a result
Springfield is a massively polluted and
politically corrupt wasteland where the
power plant dumps toxic waste wherever
it wants while the local government
gives only the occasional small fine one
of the earliest episodes finds Burns's
gubernatorial campaign sidelined by a
three-eyed fish caught in a waterway
polluted with weights toxic pollution is
just a part of life in Springfield but
is exposure to chemicals why all the
residents have sickly yellow skin
bulging eyes and four fingers on each
hand is it why they don't seem to age in
a normal way there certainly have been
even
ways that nuclear waste has profoundly
altered the lives of the residents of
Springfield and we're just waiting for
the Simpsons to answer those burning
questions check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite TV shows are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the belt so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]